hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tamra's never seen today I'm
watching Liane the professional there
has been one person in the comments of
like every single one of my videos
telling me that I should do this every
week I don't know anything about this
except for there's a very young Natalie
Portman and as you can tell I do a lot
of research before I do these episodes I
don't but I do put on fake bangs to look
more like young Natalie Portman I love
Natalie Portman as an actress and I'm
really interested to see her and I think
her first bigger role I think after this
was Garden State right and then the Star
Wars prequels oh that's a rough start
let's see how young her professional
treated her allows do it
[Music]
you
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay okay
Oh
[Music]
okay okay okay okay this movie this
movie was so good man it was beautifully
done and it was really pretty to look at
and the story was very interesting and
it was sad it was complex and I'd helped
for the characters and also it was
extremely uncomfortable which you know
is something that is a good it's a it's
an indication of a complex movie I guess
it may be very uncomfortable I did not
like the dynamic of Natalie Portman's
character being so it's just like me at
a convention I show up in full full of
cosplay and then like an hour and I'm
like okay that's enough it's too much us
to just take it off right off the bat
that assassination scene in the very
beginning really got me hooked I was
just very excited to be led in it's kind
of like when reading a book or starting
a new show on Netflix and the first
episode of the first chapter just really
grabbing it versus when they don't
you're like that is this even worth my
time if it's just not gonna grab you
right out of the gate even though waste
my time with this this it just grabbed
me and I was really excited about it the
second note that I wrote is Natalie
Portman you put that cigarette down you
are 14 years old
I think the biggest question I have from
this entire film is why does he drink so
much milk gusting I'm a type 1 diabetic
you know the doctor told me to drink
when my blood sugar is too low like I'm
past the point of helping it with like
eating it
or something the drink milk because I
have so much sugar it'll raise it
immediately that's not good
then you meet Gary Oldman's character
who is crazy if you were to run into
this person on the street you would not
stay for the whole conversation you
would walk away because it's so
unnerving how powerful and confident yet
insane and unstable this man is also I
think it only happens twice but Gary
Oldman takes these pills and those these
are it's the creepiest performance I've
ever seen it's absolutely phenomenal
it's so well done he takes it and just
like oh it's so creepy I love it it's so
great I want to see more of that that's
awesome it's so fun to see someone just
go completely batshit crazy and not to
apologize for it at all he's just nuts
in this whole performance and it's so
engaging to watch so Leon lives next
door to Natalie Portman's character
Matilda and he's been kind to her so she
decides she's gonna go buy him milk
because he loves milk so she leaves and
then Gary Oldman's character comes in
and kills her entire family which is the
pits you know it's a bummer the milk
account is higher than the body kappa
though
she really hung up it's too much he
takes her in under his wing and she
desperately wants to become a cleaner
like him hit man there's one point where
he goes into his kitchen he gets this
little pig mitt it starts talking to her
as this pig is really sweet there's some
really kind father-daughter moments and
then there's also some moments that go
beyond father-daughter and I know that
that's what they're trying to toy that
line like where is this relationship
because he's so important to her it's
her family's dead and he's taking her in
and he's giving her purpose and she's so
important to him because he's been alone
and his best friend is a plan he's doing
a really good job of being this father
figure and being the best thing in her
life which is hilarious because he's a
hit man but where is a little bit of the
line is it a little cross she also looks
just like Milly Bobby Brown we sure the
stranger kids stranger things kid and
it's crazy how similar they look but I
had noticed in the past few years
there's a lot of actresses look just
like Natalie Portman she's just a very
agreeable looking human and I think that
the woman from 13 reasons why looks a
lot like her there's there's a few
others who Hollywood knows what they
want he teaches her the ropes which is
really fun they start acting as a team
there's a few moments that are just
really great like there's a watering the
plants scene where he's watering the
plains like it's my best friend and
there's no rooms it's the best just like
me she's like it should happen if you
love that you give it roost and you
should be watering me if you want me to
grow and then he starts spraying her
with the water and she dump the water
all over him they're like running around
the house is free it's like
something that she needs as a growing
young child then there's also scenes
that are deeply uncomfortable weird like
weird they're doing make the charade
like guess who I am thing and she starts
as Madonna and then Marilyn Monroe and
then you know Charlie Chaplin then he's
John Wayne it turns into a really fun
scene but it starts off very uncle I
imagine I'm not the only one who faces I
imagine this is the thing about this
film is that it's like really good but
very uncomfortable and I know that's
what they were going for I'm not like
faulting it on that I'm just saying
right so she says that she's in love
with him Yanks that's a gang they have
to move again because she tells the
hotel concierge but he's her lover and
she's clearly going through some things
her whole family was shot down dead and
she's always been this kind of you know
beat-up source of getting shit from that
hearse like I understand it's very it's
just it sucks to watch it happen which
is I think the point of this whole thing
is with this crazy good character study
of this hit man and this over sexualized
young woman and Gary Oldman where he is
you know speaking of that everyone made
me laugh so hard
that I had to pause the movie
[Music]
this last long giant sheet obscene is so
incredibly done and really
high-intensity and it's just it's good
but then you see like a lot of love
between him and her which it's like on
one hand really sweet he's never had
this she's never had this they love each
other then on the other hand you think
spoilers he dies if he hadn't have died
it feels like it would have gone into a
bad place feels like they were just at
the break and they kept it great until
like right if he would have made it out
of this shootout scene they would have
gone to places it should not have ever
gotten to like on his way to freedom and
Gary Oldman shoots him it's a great
death scene it's really well shot like
really pretty the whole movie is really
pretty good it's really very interesting
this is from the - but he carried out
the contract blew him and Gary Oldman's
character of whose grace if Gary
Oldman's character didn't die I would
have loved to see like now Natalie
Portman and looking at too likely on the
professional Matilda the professional
now you'll want a glass of milk
no is that Millie Bobby Brown or Natalie
Portman yes John Bailey yes exactly
Matilda will make you horribly
uncomfortable yes yes charge you'll get
really uncomfortable
Lolita vibes yes you'll never get enough
of Oldman and goddammit we love him for
it absolutely mcdhh acting across the
board was absolutely incredible but Gary
Oldman was next level creep just scary
and terrifying and evil and it ruled
you'll think this is sick yet hauntingly
beautiful
and strangely romantic and I am NOT okay
with how okay I am with that ah no no I
wasn't okay with the the romance
of it I loved when they were having good
relationship II stuff in like a
father-daughter role
we're like I'm teaching you things but
I'm learning new things kind of role but
I wasn't okay with that
also if you actually do the research in
the book she rapes him so seriously
effed up but weirdly compelling movie
but also at time to drag okay I didn't
see the dragging um I didn't even know
that it was based off of a book and I
could see that because in the movie he
was very hesitant to have anything to do
with her when she would start getting
romantic so I could see that happening
in the book uncomfortable vibes great
movie though that basically yeah that's
the whole of it right there
uncomfortable vibe but it's great we'll
talk about the plant yes I've been
growing things from seeds recently and
it was fun to watch the love of the plan
jennamarbles recently put out of like 40
minute video talking about all of her
houseplants and the love she has to them
and it reminded me kind of that Jenna
the professional at first I wanted to
not enjoy it because I was like oh don't
like watching that that's not fun but I
don't know I think hopefully she was
treated well on the set it's a
thirteen-year-old girl or younger at
that point so hopefully that's not
something that stuck with her in the
moment but I do think that movies can be
uncomfortable and still be okay I think
it was a complex set of characters who
went through some shit and processing
through it so young and she's processing
through her whole family being killed
and her whole life being shit and so no
yeah I didn't love what was happening to
her of course she was acting out upon
but
I mean that was definitely the point
right just to feel that way I think it
was beautiful
I think the acting was a learn just so
good and I'm glad that I finally have
watched it definitely may be
uncomfortable though thank you so much
for watching I will see you guys all
next week with something just as
uncomfortable uhm
[Music]
that should be the thumbnail
[Applause]
you